consider the left and right Riemann sums
that would approximate the area under y
is equal to G of X between x equals 2
and x equals 8 so we want to approximate
this light blue area right over here are
the approximations over estimations or
under estimations so let's just think
about each of them let's consider the
left and the right Riemann sums
so first the left and I'm just gonna
write left 4 short but I'm talking about
the left Riemann sum so they don't tell
us how many subdivisions to make for our
approximation so that's up to us to
decide let's say we went with three
subdivisions let's say we wanted to make
them equal they don't have to be but
let's say we do so the first one would
go from 2 to 4 the next will go from 4
to 6 and the next one go from 6 to 8 if
we do a left Riemann sum you use the
left side of each of these subdivisions
in order to define the height you
evaluate the function at the left end of
each of those subdivisions for the
height of our approximating rectangles
so we would use G of 2 to approximate
for or to set the height of our first
approximating rectangle just like that
and then we would use G of 4 for the
next rectangle so we would be right over
there and then you'd use G of 6 to
represent the height of our third and
our final rectangle right over there now
when it's drawn out like this it's
pretty clear that our left Riemann sum
is going to be an over estimation why do
we know that because these rectangles
the area that they're trying to
approximate are always contained in the
rectangles and these rectangles have
this surplus area so they're always
going to be larger than the area's that
they're trying to approximate and in
general if you have a function that's
decreasing over the interval that we
care about right over here and strictly
decreasing the entire time if you use
the left edge of each subdivision to
approximate you're going to have an
overestimate because the left edge the
value of the function there is going to
be higher than the value of the function
at any other point in the subdivision
and so that's why for a decreasing
function the left Riemann sum is going
to be an over s
now let's think about the right Riemann
sum and you might already guess that's
going to be the opposite but let's
visualize that so let's just go with the
same three subdivisions but now let's
use the right side of each of these
subdivisions to define the height so for
this first rectangle the height is going
to be defined by G of 4 so that's right
over there and then for the second one
it's going to be G of 6 so that is right
over there and for the third one it's
going to be G of 8 and so let me shade
these in to make it clear which
rectangles were talking about this would
be the right Riemann sum to approximate
the area it's very clear here that this
is going to be an under estimate under
estimate because we see in each of these
intervals the Riemann the right Riemann
sum or the rectangle that we're using
for the right Riemann sum is a subset of
the area that it's trying to estimate
we're not able to it doesn't capture
this extra area right over here and once
again that is because this is a strictly
decreasing function so if you use the
right endpoint of any one of these or
the right side of any of these
subdivisions in order to define the
height that right value of G is going to
be the lowest value of G in that
subdivision and so it's going to be a
lower height than what you could even
say is the average height of the value
of the function over that interval so
you're going to have an underestimate in
this situation now if your function was
strictly increasing then these two
things would be swapped around and of
course there are many functions that are
neither strictly increasing or
decreasing and then it would depend on
the function and real and sometimes even
it would depend on the type of
subdivisions you choose to decide
whether you have an overestimate or an
underestimate